the academy awards airs this sunday at
8pm
on abc the famous home of the academy
awards and obviously
we are dressed up for the occasion
myself ross matthews did you notice
we're here
with our fellow family entertainment
tonight's kevin frazier and michelle
turner
hi okay now let's look at the nominees
for best supporting actress
michelle take us away well you know what
i think that uh
ya zhang yoon will take this one home
i think that it's a great category again
with amanda seifried olivia coleman
for the father um you've also got glenn
close for hillbilly elegy and maria
bakalova
for borat which was a surprise to a lot
of people but she was
so good she was fantastic she was
fantastic
and you know i think that there is um
some folks that sentimentally would like
to see glenn close
win uh this award but she's been
nominated 412 times and never won
yes i think that this could be her year
everybody comes back and they say you
know what we oh glenn girl let me
check my ballot i don't think so right
now jung yoon
is going to win the oscar she deserves
to yes i think that that she's going to
win this award can i just also just say
how great is it that maria buckalevo was
nominated for a comedy
it doesn't happen enough more comedy
should be nominated
i completely agree and we're honored to
have maria
on our show tonight i cannot wait to get
into it fantastic
that's so exciting all right let's see
who our vff's predicted
will win best supporting actress
oh come on now here's what's happening
i'm telling you what's happening
everybody gets sentimental
everybody gets now you guys have got me
jazzed for sunday night see what
wouldn't happen
and we don't know what's going to happen
so we tune in because ooh
will there be an upset yeah this
category would where there could be a
big surprise all right well i'm really
excited about this
category uh the nominees for best
director nichelle this is another
history breaking moment in this category
correct we've got chloe zhao who is
director for nomed land and we also have
emerald fennell
who directed promising young women two
women in the best director category
is phenomenal
it's a it's a first which is cool we
hope it's not a last exactly absolutely
but i do think that and we're going to
see chloe zhao win this
i think she's going to take uh this home
for nomad land
but don't count up minari yeah
absolutely you're correct about that
when people see that movie
they are truly transported and moved
now let's see who our vff's picked for
best director
they picked chloe
yeah smart you got a smart group there
well we i think i think uh we got lucky
uh people are invested in this and
finally who will take the cake
let's look at the nominees for best
picture kevin take it away
and this is one where you fight with
your heart and your head
yeah to figure out which one is the best
there are great movies look
i thought that judas and the black
messiah was the best movie of the year
kevin and i agree on this i
i think it is unbelievable the
performances are incredible yeah
incredible i love it i do think that
no mad land or menari will win yes best
picture
well i agree about nomad land it has
swept everything
but trial of the chicago seven is that
historical drama that you know
the academy loves to award and it's so
well crafted
all right let's see who our vff's picked
oh
trial of the chicago seven seven watch
out
i do think we've come into an era
where all bets are off um the world has
changed the world has lifted
and we cannot wait to see what happens
on sunday night do you know what i'm
excited about drew
getting my ballot so that we can fill
them out for michelle i can see
do this well monday morning i know what
we'll all be talking about
and i just want to thank you nichelle
and kevin
our sister show our brothers show
entertainment tonight
watch e.t five nights a week on cbs i
know i do